teresa huff rang in 2022 with what she
calls a mild case of covid but it's the
symptoms she thinks the virus left
behind that has her searching for a
solution
i noticed it probably the first week in
february but it may have even been
before that just at night the ringing
you know the ringing in my ears
that's just one example of tinnitus a
constant buzz whoosh or ringing in the
ears 37 percent of canadians have to
endure the annoying and uncomfortable
condition which is believed to be an
inflammatory response or a result of
stress and in march of 2021 a group of
researchers found tinnitus was reported
by 15 percent of covid patients
audiologist rex banks says pandemic
anxiety and isolation may be to blame
during the pandemic people who
you know are spending more time alone
for example they may be spending more
time in silence meaning that they may
become more aware of their tinnitus but
there is another possible explanation
for the last year researchers have
studied the inner ear cells of both
humans and mice and found covid19 does
have the ability to infect some of the
cells which can underlie problems with
hearing or balance the vaccine or covet
is sort of triggering
this inner inner hair cells to
exasperate their existing tinnitus you
know just like it's affecting smell or
taste
thousands of incidents of
vaccine-related tinnitus have been
reported around the world including six
cases in johnson and johnson's own
coveted shot trial still it's a rare
ramification and experts agree the
benefits of the vaccine far outweigh the
risk matt willis is boosted but it was
after his bout with covid in november he
says he too noticed the high-pitched
sound of tinnitus had become more
intense i have to find ways to try and
concentrate
and i'm not fixating on the
on the on the sound the whole time
drowning out the noise and learning to
live with a condition with no cure
jamie morocco global news toronto